hey guys so this is one of our uncut
video podcasts you know all one giant
take it's meant to just be you know
listen to well forget one day how to put
our [ __ ] on iTunes and Spotify and all
that this is probably the most fun
podcast we've ever filmed very early on
we have a boom mic that is separate from
the mics were speaking into that starts
falling into frame and it happens really
early on and becomes a little bit that
we start playing off of but yeah we
recorded this on 4/20 so it could
explain what we missed a couple of
things but this is one of the most fun
podcasts we've ever done so hopefully
you guys enjoy feel free to chime in on
the comments on why your dream Avengers
team would be hello there reject nation
i'm greg alba no no I'm Joan Humphrey we
are going to do a special video podcast
today one of our top of war tears at
patreon youtubers with patron pages I
don't get tired of hearing about people
talk about it never so I love talking
about it top 40 or whatever video your
question must do and put up on YouTube
and today is a very different kind of
podcast um so this is basically where's
this screenshot here that we took this
from Chris melio who has an awesome
awesome content on the internet an
awesome content on the Internet one
awesome yeah all guys need to go view it
and engage with it he was saying I was
thinking for this month and now that you
two have those mics I'd like to see both
of you each pitch your dream team
Avengers lineup
I'd say limit it to a team of six each
ooh that changes it and you can pull
from I thought it was five for some
reason and you could pull from any
Marvel character that had been on the
big screen or in a live-action TV show
yeah she okay
so a Fiats and all like he's had
examples oh he's even including Tom
Hardy's venom then Ryan Reynolds was
Deadpool so anything Marvel related
basically is what yeah they're going for
here any live-action MCU character thus
far
so okay and if you guys even want to get
a little movie fight inspire argue whose
team would win in a fight John why don't
you we haven't had a two days to write
up several notes for that sometimes you
get two days so John why don't you go
pitch your team hi I came up with mine
pretty quick okay I haven't written any
new time I just have like I got a very
basic idea let's see what comes out of
my noggin I got a basic idea too and I
kind of organized it with a specific
reason in mine for why I chose each
particular character okay and I wanted
to not only choose dudes for some of
these I have alternate characters by
feminism ruining this country
anyway the leader of my personal
Avengers team is spider-man Allah
you know Sam Raimi's films because it is
still my favorite spider-man and I think
that if you set you know my Avengers
universe after the events of spider-man
1 2 & 3
he is the spider-man on the big screen
that has the most kind of battle-tested
emotional maturity as well as you know
all the other physical combat stuff and
you know the principal and everything so
I feel like he would be a great leader
then my second-in-command
or my second and third you know my other
is sort of - left and right-hand advisor
types would first be rogue because I
think her power would be really
beneficial yes and you know take other
people's powers and stuff and absorb
them and she's got other things as well
before and I think she would especially
with what she's had to overcome as a
character over time if you don't count
last stand is pretty great and something
that you know an Avengers team could
benefit from then my other sort of you
know right left hand character would
either be storm or Doctor Strange
because I would want somebody with some
kind of very huge level of power storm
you know obviously is one of those
powerful x-men characters she can
control the weather and you know the
atmosphere she has you know an emotional
connection with those things which I
also think is really cool and I think
somebody with that level of emotion on
the team would be interesting or Doctor
Strange who has you know the magic and
the realm hopping edge
you know I think he would be a terrific
asset to the team then just for a more
tactical side of things I would want
Nightcrawler
yeah because Nightcrawler you know you
could break in you can do stealth
because you can hide in the shadows talk
to the can don't look at my paper right
I keep up all the characters you have
okay I'll say have spider-man right now
rogue storm storm or Doctor Strange
Nightcrawler to make a decision then
ant-man or the wasp which is really easy
because that would be like the same
thing and so for also for tactical I
thought ant-man or the wasp you can
interchange those to Jesus Christ anyway
ant-man or the wasp because they have
the benefit of growing and shrinking
both I'll kind of have similar powers in
a lot of ways and you have the knowledge
of the quantum realm which would be a
great you know again asset to have to
your team and then the last you know the
sixth spot I I thought should be
somebody who's down on the street level
who is capable of helping the people my
ideal choice that would be Luke Cage
from the TV show and I think he would be
great because you know obviously he's
got you know unbreakable skin and all
that stuff and so he would be great to
help civilians out and to you know do a
lot of you know like physical combat and
stuff like that and a lot of them can or
Jessica Jones I thought you know could
be another sort of good on the street
person because she too has heightened
strength and agility and and healing and
all that stuff so hmm so these would be
my ideal sort of main picks here there
are a couple others who I considered but
ultimately I die lift on the the cutting
room floor of this hypothetical who are
they fighting who are they fighting or
they versing I have a team but who are
they versed Galactus it's a crossover
who's Galactus from the DC Universe what
does he do he's swallows worlds and
stuff is that all he does no he's just
power he just goes around I don't have
time to get into it now I want to hear
your team a way to where to pivot I
didn't have to
there was nothing in question that told
me I was supposed to pick a villain and
that's how you lose on movie fight
people you don't prepare your story
their villain the villain is a toxic
fandom because this is going to be a
sci-fi even more sci-fi where the
Avengers have been ripped out of the
movie world into our world and they have
to acclimate oh so it's like last action
here yeah exactly but with the event who
would direct your film John McTiernan of
course out of jail or wherever easy I
don't know hey that's really cool thanks
man I knew you were if you were on movie
fights that would be the perfect my
eight my movie is not a movie fight
sorry my movie I I freaked okay look if
this was because I'm only talking about
movie faces Chris brought up yeah I know
I've been on movie fight several times
and I take my page I like I really think
about my pitches and I thought like okay
well I'm not on movie fights it's real
reject that's just how you can have fun
I just want to have fun and and I did
always have this an idea a joke idea
that I have now turned into what the
child's play remake trailer is like
where it's like what was a funny joke
I'm gonna now serious take three
Howard's the duck no two Deadpool's half
a Wolverine and half a Captain America
my my idea that came to me really quick
is when I thought of the team I'd want
and then I thought of how I've always
loved the I've read at one time and this
was years ago when I read it and it's
such a short story but I've my ideas
basically inspired by the fragments of
memory I have from the comic book of
Punisher kills the Marvel Universe
because I've always thought like oh you
know when Marvel is when this timeline
is ending when they get to a point where
no one could keep it with this [ __ ]
anymore
for sixty movies down the road it was
like I want I don't want to go back 50
movies to start this is you know yeah
when they're like you gotta do a total
reboot we got to start from the
beginning again if we want to keep
Marvel alive I thought I'd be cool to do
like Punisher kills the Marvel Universe
but I thought alright but now I'm in
this like rules and limitations because
of the team of characters you're you're
dealing with here do you get one extra
yes so basically what I thought of this
movie would be a two-parter where it's
at what I remember in the comic book
feel free to correct it because like
it's arrow what time forever ago I was
looking for it but then I remembered
that I already put it in a box cuz we're
packing getting ready to move so and
sure I could what what really yeah happy
we're moving out I don't think you
forgot about that's what these boxes are
interesting I thought I was just
becoming a hoarder again so my first
movie would be where Punisher I haven't
finished season 2 so I don't know where
we left off a frank castle because we
kills the Marvel Universe Frank Castle
is now he's remarried and he has kids
no and then a like like in Punisher
kills this is the first movie like him
Punisher kills the Marvel Universe his
family gets caught in a crossfire
between heroes and villains and they all
die and he blames the heroes right so in
this what I remembered being like a 10
page copy could it's it's much longer
than that but it's so surprisingly short
and wildly entertaining so basically in
the story of Part 1 because if I want to
get to part 2 you right away so in part
1 yeah yeah why do the first yeah he's
just like he's just zooming through all
the Marvel heroes right he just ends up
killing everyone and by the end of it he
manages to get like all these people in
the same room all these people in the
same room or something I remember
something like that happens in the
combat game basically like eventually
nukes them all and then BAM he kills he
kills everyone ok and then in part 2
this is the dream team movie you have
now six characters left standing
and there are their own there no one
with superpowers
alright that's my whole team Coulson
because you really really elevate the
stakes if he kills all these people with
superpowers and the only heroes you have
left are the people without superpowers
then you're really [ __ ] right yeah so
the leader of my team is the one person
with some powers but he doesn't have
super speed he doesn't have super
strength he doesn't know he can't fly
against her invisible
it's daredevil Daredevils the lead of it
he's the only one with some slight
superpowers he enhanced hearing the ants
sent all the handsets is right that
enhanced sense of touch is really going
to come in handy touch so many things to
make sure do the mission right and I
thought I'd kept my phone off of luck
okay then of course the second character
you know you got to get Hawkeye or Ronan
where he's left off at this at this
stage in it and the third character it
would be Black Widow and see ya I feel
like Hawkeye cuz it you still get the
variety in a way and I think it's always
cooler especially if you're on something
like movie fights to pitch like you're
wide variety of superpowers right and I
got a wide variety of skills here it's
like my team okay
so Hawkeye and black widow both have
military background that could go up
against Frank Castle pretty well they
kind of try to forget into his mindset
and then you also have you have a Koi a
and because I imagine the nuke thing
happened near the east code where you
got everyone together you have a Koi a
or maybe in Wakanda I don't know I'm
spitballing this Okoye and Sheree okay
because II then you got your science so
you got the person with the spear you
got the person with the bow and arrow
you got black widow who scissors your
neck and you have Sheree who's the the
person the inventor and stuff can help
them track stuff and I think goes all my
characters right oh so my last one just
for fun because it doesn't fit and he
doesn't really fit in star-lord because
he's part of the guardians of the galaxy
but he doesn't have any superpowers
that's true he's just good at like
zipping around on jetpacks and it's like
well we because then he relinquished all
that at the end ago
- yeah I think otherwise if he had super
powers like ego really could have come
in handy against Thanos yes sirs yeah oh
man I love your idea I want to see that
movie
so yeah and it's these guys left
standing and then of course daredevil
has a very personal relationship with
our main villain because he thought that
Punisher might have been going down a
good path because you know we had his
own two seasons on Netflix and he
defended him on trial like Frank Castle
as he understands his place in the world
you know yeah but this is like something
we're a long time ago he should have
killed Punisher yeah I know bleachers
killed everyone because what I imagine
of of how this can sort of go down and
I'm totally just going on this could
totally go down is maybe something along
the lines of he Punisher breaks out
kingpin because kingpin is a because I
haven't seen season three of daredevil
but basically he apparently owns
everything in the government okay okay
it's kind of really you know CIA is
there he basically has powers of I don't
know if that's how it all is there but
that's what it starts to feel like so he
uses him to be able to find out where
everyone is cuz he can't go to like
Black Widow or something you know okay
but then by the end of may be a part one
or at the beginning of part two he even
kills kingpin because now he has no use
for him yeah so one by one throughout my
movie Punisher slowly kills them all off
and then Punisher kills everyone and
eventually just kills Marvel movie ever
I know my idea would never happen my
ideas you'll never see me want it to
have your ideas a million times more
likely than mine my idea ain't ever
gonna happen I don't know I chose
characters that I liked and thought
would also be smart but I really love
the the whimsical just hyper violent see
a bleak nihilistic oh yeah one off that
you've come to movies like I see the
thing is I want to live on the timeline
where those get financed you see it's
like I feel like all of my characters
can have
one-on-one fight with Punisher if I were
to take my idea seriously he would have
you know or you could see Okoye a
working up against him and who is it
against okay okay Sheree
Hawkeye black widow dare dare star-lord
head start over reading the humor to it
and that he's the major all those lost
moment nice nice when he seen is lost
moment for just a different characters
about to die yeah because they're like
similar to infinity war you know
Punishers really the main character in
part one okay then in part two it's
adventure Avengers I have it's gotta be
like a Devil's Rejects sort of thing
we're in the first half yeah you feel
for the Punisher and you're like oh man
yeah these people have destroyed your
second family yeah and but then yeah
partway through that but yeah it's like
and I love that because that also kind
of to me pokes fun it like the John
McClane's of the cinematic landscape
words like how many times is gonna
happen you know yes so like I love the
whimsy of the second family but yeah you
could spend the whole first movie be
like I get this guy and the more violent
he becomes you're like oh yeah I get
this guy and then it's like the Devil's
Rejects we're in the second half you're
like well I hope the heroes get away or
you know and then yeah you all comes
down to the end and then the punisher
wins and he kills himself and then we
all go home sad yeah we reboot the whole
thing and then we're like I think we're
done with comic Thank You Quentin
Tarantino come on man let's talk more
about your idea my idea is a story a
little story a little come on John yeah
more improv experience than I do a
little story I mean the thing is I don't
know I think tell me about their
dynamics their dynamics to go what are
the things we want to see in an Avengers
movie we want to see them bicker but
ultimately learn how to work together as
a team I feel like that's always what
what partially happens if something
comes into too
them all up yes distrusting of each
other and between all these different
characters it would have to be something
very personal so like it would have to
be then uh you know maybe dr. strange or
maybe you know maybe somebody hooked up
with somebody else and because you know
Tobey Maguire spider-man you got to have
that relationship angle you know you got
to have there be some kind of romantic
tension and there's also got to be
tension with his best friend Doctor
Strange okay because doctors okay if
it's if it's is is I forget this this is
storm like a scientist in regular life
when she's not being I mean I know she
teaches at the x-men Academy I don't
know what scientist I don't know what
any of them teach the x-men Academy well
either way I feel like tober one image
of Cyclops showing them his bike yeah
like what are you teaching yeah be cool
like thirteen-year-old kids right yeah
in one of those centers spread those
kinds of panels are drama yeah well
those two-page spreads you know like I
feel like Spider Man would be really
into like being chummy with either storm
or dr. strange because they have like
either meteorological or just scientific
expertise okay yeah now I feel like
Nightcrawler would be the kind of like
remote one of the group sure cuz you
know he likes to hide the shadows he's
used to the circus life and stuff like
that how would he interact with the most
he would probably interact the most with
rogue okay his rogue understands what
it's like to feel like such an outsider
and a pariah and to have kind of even
though she is a normal looking woman he
is a strange looking guy right like his
appearance has kept him from people but
her ability has kept her from people so
they hook up yeah they do awesome you
know that may teleport while they're
hooking up like yeah because I mean like
his powers I woke up is it's later in
the comics rogue gets control over her
power and so I'm hoping that because you
know we have the benefit of you we've
seen rogue in several movies I don't
know if it has to be the same and a
Paquin rogue but you know I feel
like she's a little bit older now maybe
she's mastered her power maybe she's
getting there but not quite and there's
a scene where she's like do you trust me
and he's like I I don't care I just I I
I want you so bad I love you so much my
name's Mike Rowe he's gonna be like but
the thing about this Nightcrawler is
he's gonna be like the beastly version
all this thing is really dipped into
France version I been a little while
[Music]
Podcast gone wrong it's okay it's okay
if you are in the video it's 20 minutes
in it's safe to tell you guys now we are
filming this on 4/20 yes but but even so
I mean yeah there would be tension there
but he's gonna he's gonna be
Nightcrawler but not like okay you know
how Alan [ __ ] Nightcrawler and Kodi
smit-mcphee Nightcrawler are pretty like
creature like I'm gonna have this be
like a beastly type of movie where he's
Nightcrawler but he's sexy Nightcrawler
you know like like the designs on his
skin and the blue complexion are just
like you know quirks but that highlight
his you I love that we're going off-road
with this that highlight you know and
accentuate the contours of his face and
just make him look that much more
beautiful and yeah there's gonna be a
scene where rogue is like you know I
don't know I don't want to you know I
don't want to drain you of your life
force and he's like you know do you
trust me and she's like yeah and he's
like well then let's go and at first yes
she is absorbing his power but then they
start transporting throughout the
different worlds and it's through this
hookup that she's able to finally click
and connect and gain control of her
powers as they both orgasm in you know
cosmic Wonder and yeah I'm do that's
that's some second okay I really want to
play I gotta put some sexy in my story
than yeah okay I got it there's gonna be
a big fight and all that stuff but
there's also gonna be like really
interpersonal dynamics all right
okay so mine
and BlackWidow have children and they
all die all right so their relationship
is strained and eventually to get this
is this is like that B story that just
feels very unnecessary for the movie and
it really is yeah is when haka is when
star-lord and Black Widow starts
sleeping with each other and do one of
those shots in the movie where you see
Hawkeye standing in the doorway lily
frame because he knows now so we get
really sideline by affairs yeah you know
whatever it takes okay yeah yeah that's
good it really won't ever come full
circle because they just die this never
gets resolved I really hope that is a
structural earmark of your Avengers
world where you set up you keep so you
say so much setup story and it just gets
kid that all set it up like it's all
gonna mean something like wow and then
just have this yet really staccato story
life is not a movie and that's why
that's what Punisher represents here is
that we are destroying everything now
because none of this [ __ ] is is real or
important and we treat it like it's so
important and that we need it so
Punisher Rex Rex at all yeah he's just a
troll and so that's why in life like do
you think most people who die completed
everything they needed to or went
through all the character arcs in the
real life though they needed to know
Punisher comes in stops all the
character always a dose of reality
yeah no more arcs just great great set
up yeah and my movie would be directed
by Nicolas wooden in roughen Heroes
walking into frame fists clenched
turning doing like an about-face staring
at each other for a while not a serious
no sin
Nicholas when Reverend would make a
great Punisher stand alone he would be
angry people make a when you know that
she would be [ __ ] disgusting
he would make a wonderful with Ryan
Gosling playing Punisher yeah I know I
love it
dice is here actually Brian Gosling if
he didn't look I don't know I love him
and everything
yeah but forget that kind of that later
in there's 20 or 49 look of Ryan Gosling
not blond hair blue eyed but like around
here yeah yeah yeah a little darker he
might would actually make any get buff
up he actually make a pretty good
Punisher he's good at playing the lost
angry times he is you just have to get
jacked bad we got more ideas and we even
ask for Chris yeah which idea I could
punish your movie starring Adrien Brody
which I which I do closing arguments I
didn't even get to finish who all's
hooking up in my movie I mean like I
mean I feel like spider-man would be
hooking up with with closing arguments I
think this is a good Avengers team I
wish I'd picked a better villain because
I've had like three villains laid out
here one of them is very meta all the
last action hero one of them is from the
DC EU and or the DC universe at large
anyway and one of them is you know
metaphorical I don't really know if I
could argue I have the better movie here
I just have an arguably good Avengers
team that I like and also think would be
a pretty good Avengers team okay I think
your movie is a way better than mine
because I want to see like you know okay
my movie may not be as wide and variety
as expected like what John Humphrey has
put down hey because that is what we
would normally that's more along the
lines of what we expect to see who would
expect your final Avengers movie to be
the movie where you have the some of the
most least praised of characters that
you can see you know because they're I
mean yeah we all like
of all these characters that I listed
sure but at the same time you know
they're not the ones you'd expect to be
the final one standing and this ain't
the final villain you'd expect to be
standing and what's more inspiring than
a having it's a relatable that people go
up against a relatable villain because
because if we need real you know we're
always being like you could be a hero to
little boy you could be a hero to little
girl but it's like unless I get bit by a
radioactive spider or get hit by a
tesseract blowing up I'm not gonna be
able to have any of these cool abilities
you know but these are people who have
worked hard train hard
develop these skills over years and
years of training alright my new team is
gonna be Coulson Cobie Smulders agent
Peggy Carter like John please that is
the follow-up to my Nick Fury will be in
yours
so yeah that's and it ends with a little
boy being able to telekinetically grab a
broom as he looks off into space
ooh magneto you have no idea what I just
did do you know there's a lost Jedi yeah
but rise of the sky I I think something
has come loose over there I think I
think some things and it is drooping but
one thing is for sure you guys have not
enjoyed this podcast as much as we've
had filming it yeah but if you made it
this far I'm glad you're here
Chris Greg wins the podcast I don't win
the pot yes we both came up with the way
there's there's probably a way where you
and I can meet halfway okay and be able
to combine our ideas yeah like I like
the idea of like rogue and Black Widow
hooking up in my idea you know well I
was gonna say see here's the things I
was thinking we could get with since I
have alternates we have so many
possibilities here I'm sure
sure because like think about it I think
I think spider-man and jessica jones
could work and that's not you know crazy
but what about like Luke Cage and Doctor
Strange like them hooking up yeah dude
how cool would that be or located a
spider-man because they're both from New
York yeah but something of teenage
spider-man grown tobey maguire
spider-man in and I don't know not
everybody is their exact actor but that
one is look guys I'm trying to find the
name of Christmas channel so we can
close this out and I just can't remember
isn't it called may you yes yes you're
right and that's probably the way you
pronounce his actual last name oh my god
it makes sense now I think it's got to
why is it mm you know may use a singer
yeah I know guys we're trying as
professional as possible this is yeah
this is same [ __ ] Mister Rogers John
keep us entertained it's a beautiful day
in the neighborhood
gonna hook up in this story I mean if I
go a storm instead of Doctor Strange
Luke Cage and storm would be cool also
uh Punisher and daredevil would have a
fight on top of the Empire State
Building and it would be it would be oh
yeah yeah be raining okay okay I mean I
would have my movie be one long take I
would have my movie just be one long
take just like instead of like a 1 1
take fight 1 take movie oh my mu B 2
some might say it's an impossible
challenge yeah so we could close this
out properly oh I know how to find
Chris's channel I just got a ok don't
worry guys I know you all really want to
go to Chris's channel bye what all this
is your shout out in this video Chris I
hope you I hope you're okay with that
as I told myself that's going to go over
30 minutes and we
gone over 30 minutes doing a lot of
nonsense here and I'm really sorry hey
man we're going off-roading it's fun it
is I mean is channel matter is Manu ma
why why oh you but his name look guys
this great segment called nostalgia
worry it's not a let's play but it
really kind of goes it's like an
in-depth review discussion some great
editing for video games he really loved
so I think you guys should go check it
out covers the re-releases in HD so
thank you guys
how would you better our ideas or these
movies make our teams and pitch your own
how would what would be your Avengers
lineup and your story idea which one of
these ideas that you like more why by
the way I'm not saying choose one of
these to answer I'm saying answer them
all yes if every comment is not a
paragraph I'm gonna be upset I expect an
essay yeah as much as creative writing
assignment yeah how would you what what
did you like about our ideas and what
would you change about our ideas but
keep subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell you could check
us out on patreon I'm sure this is worth
Chris's time see you guys later peace